foreign
[Applause]
good people
I wish good people were here
happy Tuesday everyone turns out thanks
to this smashing success of this show
which happened because of our awesome
fans and my Razor wit and my washboard
abs other networks now want to hit
comedy show of their own according to
the news site semaphore CNN is
reportedly considering hiring a comedian
to host one of its Primetime shows makes
sense the network is still a joke
that's mean apparently some floated
names that included Bill Maher Trevor
Noah Arsenio Hall and John Stewart what
Noah Lane boozler
Elaine boozler
Elaine boozler I'm just gonna say it
Elaine boozler anyway but if they really
want comedy they should relaunch CNN
plus oh
that debacle made me laugh far more than
the dead crow stapled to Chris Wallace's
scalp
but isn't that the point really CNN was
already funny and they went ahead and
they ruined it I'm talking of course
about the Golden Age of Comedy Chris
Cuomo Don Lemon Brian stelter
or as they're known in the business The
Three Stooges
those were the days right now
everything's ruined Chris lost his gig
after trying to help his brother Andrew
fend off a sexual harassment Scandal
which is like having Alec Baldwin teach
you gun safety
kill the lady and and lemon lost his
prime time gig becomes because he comes
off as real as this guy's breasts
and no offense to that guy and his giant
fake
he is a Global treasure stelter sadly
for us took time off to spend more time
with his Hoagies
did you know he gave blood last week
that's how they make Alfredo sauce
[Laughter]
disgusting
I know it's gross but how could CNN
forget these guys were a ride when they
were together remember this classic
if you watch a certain State TV and you
listen to conservative media you would
think that you know entire cities are
just you know in Broad and fights and
fires and whatever we went out had a
great dinner in New York City tonight
the only thing that could have made that
funnier is him bursting into flames
after he said it
[Music]
I'll never get tired of that and who can
forget this
looking ahead to 2020 one reason why I'm
taking you seriously as a contender is
because of your presence on cable news
for president
I heard dentists use this clip because
it's cheaper than laughing gas why they
can't that guy's show instead of
promoting him his Bonkers but the thing
is regardless of our show's amazing
success if CNN wants to chase comedy
they should start by first being real I
know that's like asking Spielberg to do
a sequel to Schindler's List using Alvin
and the Chipmunks
don't steal that idea but that's because
comedy follows honesty and if you can't
be truthful good luck being funny take
the late great Norm Macdonald after O.J
Simpson's acquittal in 95 he said well
it's official it's finally official
murder is legal in the state of
California
the audience roared because they knew it
was true but they also laughed because
Norm was saying something he got the
feeling he wasn't supposed to say rumors
swirled that some execs at NBC didn't
want him doing OJ jokes he was willing
to break the rules to tell the truth
so how can a network do that while
calling moms pregnant people in order to
be effective at comedy you got to rely
on Truth not ideology CNN is sort of
trans in that way
meaning they identify as truthful
[Laughter]
but they still never really made the cut
hey
remember what we refer to as CNN's
Easter when Chris Cuomo rose from the
dead from his basement
after being quarantined with covid just
a week after fighting a cyclist
do you remember this during 2020 a
reporter does a hit outside a burning
building while the on-screen caption
reads mostly peaceful protests now
that's dishonesty but it's hilarious
unintentionally we could be here all
night reciting examples from CNN's
years-long perpetuation of the Russian
myth to Nick Sandman Jesse Smith to
their 12-headed panels of gibbering
cockatoos all tried out hysteria each
other
remember when every day was worse than
Watergate
this is worse than Watergate is worse
than Watergate this in some ways is
worse than Watergate his face is worse
than Watergate
yeah
but anyway so before CNN entertains any
fantasies about comedy first you got to
tackle the truth take it from your
humble host each night we start from the
truth then go from there where we go
each night who the hell knows sometimes
it's hilarious other times it's not
but remember that with comedy the
outcome is not predetermined it's why
woke comedy can't be funny well Comics
are nothing more than smirking
deliverers of bitter lectures and it's a
tell that they require you to agree
rather than laugh and that's because
there's no equity in laughter you either
laugh or you don't try to establish a
quota and you'll be the joke
let's
[Applause]
tonight's guests
she's known for her cheerleading and
leading your ears bleeding outnumbered
co-host Emily campagno
his comedy is so dark every ticket to
his show comes with a free headlamp
comedian Kurt Metzger
he dresses like a magician because he
can make laughter disappear oh
Sam Fox Across America Jimmy Fallon
and she's never been told that she
lights up a room Fox News contributor
cat tip
all right
a little a little trivia here about Kurt
Metzger he was we're I believe the
original liberal panel on the Gutfeld
show when we used to have the talking
wall it was him that's true yeah it was
a puppeteer and writer on the show
it's not paid for either of those yes
you're not paid
not on your CV you don't brag about it I
understand do you have any comedy advice
for CNN
well okay the names they floated were
like I guess the last names the execs
have heard of right yeah so okay let's
say you land a great host you know you
get like uh Trevor Noah a guy with a
perfectly round head yes that's not easy
to get
all right
yeah you got that it really is a matter
of what writers are you gonna get for
that I don't know if people think these
hosts write the jokes but they don't and
where are you gonna find all the like
trans writers of color to fill the the
comedy I think you haven't gotten the
trans queer writers yet so don't count
why why are you counting yourself out if
you identify Kurt yep what do you
identify as these days uh
it's fluid
gender fluid well I'm uh able fluid I
would call
like I hurt my back recently
wow so you take two boxes your gender
fluid and your and you might be
handicapped yeah I think you got a gig
just got promoted yes yes you are
disabled Jimmy hey girl yes
why no that was a complimentation it's a
pro-jimmy crowd that's approach yes yes
so it's a home game for the church um
do you work with tigers now
it's from my Carol Baskin collection
um
it's so funny what do you gain from this
story I this isn't about blowing our own
horn it's not that it's all over the
place now well it first of all it is
kind of hilarious that every Network
wants to walk a mile in your shoes but
they can't because they're a size three
you know what I mean I owed you one I
owed you one shut up that hurts uh I
have angles here okay the first one is
that they're saying they're going down
this route because Chris Licht is a late
night expert because he produced Colbert
yeah that's like saying you're a
babysitting expert because you hung out
with Casey Anthony
I mean let's just get it out of the way
but the point you guys both made and
it's the reason they have crippled late
night comedy is because when you go woke
you take all the targets off the table
you have rules about punching up instead
of punching down and you've got to read
the rooms how to lead the room and
that's what happened the Democrats by
taking the fun out of their party
screwed the comedians that kind of
gravitated towards their party I can
give you a modern example last week the
Democrats voted against allowing cigars
inside the capital 20 years ago they
were fine with cigars inside interns you
know what I'm saying
[Applause]
good thing here
I like that you you went a long way into
the ball listen we have time between
takes on Tiger King we can dig in you
know what I mean I love the fact that
one of the networks uh one of the
sources said they're looking for their
John Oliver is that aren't they all John
Oliver's are they all the same version
of John Oliver the sake of my God that's
so funny Emily welcome to the show
thanks you're welcome do you have
anything interesting to add to this
conversation
rom-com
whole plot is someone trying to be
someone they're not right at the end of
Greece like like you you can't be the
person that you're not the the the the
nerd can't be the hot girl or whatever
it is although I think like some of them
can for a second but the point is that
no matter what happens to CNN they're
always going to revert back because
they're looking for their John Oliver
but what they really are trying to find
is their own you and that's never going
to happen so Chris Licht said when he
took over don't make him ego any bigger
you guys know I'm everybody
like a sitcom line I'm nice and we're
looking for John Oliver but what he
really needed was you
we'll be right back Flix said he like
put out an email and said you guys may
not like this you may be confused he
said in an email to everyone but he said
but I am trying to have rational
conversations around polarizing topics
so you're going to try to be Fox you
just have normal conversations about
topics that people feel heated about
that's incendiary according to Oberman
Keith Oberman who is one of those sacked
he's called him a fascist because of it
Heaven helped the fact that finally two
years after exposing himself in front of
the entire company Jeffrey tubin was
actually gone so while they're making
small strides by the way that was the
end of this joke of all 100 percent
at the end of the day a tiger can't
remove his stripes and CNN cannot depart
from the fact that they are at the end
of the day the joke themselves what do
you wouldn't make
thank you
cat I thought they were going to go back
to covering straight news but now
they're looking at us and they're going
hmm what are they doing over there maybe
we need a cat tip of our own
would you steal her don't take her I I
just love that for this counts as an
idea yeah like they're doing a comedy
and it's going well so we should also do
a comedy
if I want to be an executive if that's
what counts as contributing something to
a conversation that's all you have to do
because they they didn't say how it
would be different or unique or
something that's already out there
there's like this other thing is good so
we should also have our own good thing
and then that actually gets reported on
that's an actual discussion obviously
this show there's nothing else like this
show whether you like it or you don't
like it there is anything else like it
so how would theirs be different they
have not discussed that which again I
want to be a CEO why is why is CNN
talking about this and not like the
networks with guys comments yeah we
should do a comedy here yeah at cnh
Comedy Central should go you know what
we should start doing comedy
no but you're right you're right it is
funny that it the whole thing is flipped
and it's Fox which is concerned you know
you think right wing you think every
stereotype that goes with it and yet
like we're the only person doing what's
basically like a rough or rough crowd
type show where you could say it's like
a sign of the Apocalypse it is there's
something wrong I might be Satan
I do drink the blood of children but
that's just a coincidence that's my skin
looking great hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else